spiders do not freak out breathe breathe
hello my name's Anne Jones and I host
the ABCs nature podcast off track and
today we're going to be looking at
videos of love them or hate them
huntsman spiders okay
patented broom method to try and usher
the spider out wouldn't recommend it
that's why I wouldn't recommend it
husband can jump and they can move with
considerable speed they're pretty
coordinated with their eight legs
they've also got hairy little Tootsie's
and that means that they can grip onto
basically anything so you know from the
roof to the face of someone with a broom
what did he expect to happen you didn't
even hold the container on it first
start bad container choice doesn't sit
flat against the surface also it's best
if they're see-through so you can
actually see if you've got the spider
she has the right idea a huntsman
is going to like to hide behind
something because they're made for
hiding in between you know a tree in the
bark in the trees he's just turning
himself inside out whether he about a
silly spider I'm not surprised he didn't
catch it because huntsman are really
fast because they're huntsmen that means
they hunt for their food so they can
move it something like 40 body lengths a
second Usain Bolt runs like five body
lengths a second
so these spiders are running a lot
faster okay
why is he got it on his hand
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well actually we don't allowed friends
like that spiders all right so even
though they're not harmful to humans
they're still going to give you a fright
these guys will only bite when they've
been absolutely really hassled into it
and they have pretty big things so they
can pierce human skin but they have
fairly weak venom so it means that you
might get a reaction and swelling but
really it's not going to hurt you beyond
that that's a fleshie huntsman that is a
pygmy possum so it's not a mouse and you
can tell because the tail is really
thick huntsmen are pretty famous in
Australia for being the big spiders and
you often notice them immediately before
you go to bed that's because they're
active in the Twilight hours and at
night so they go out hunting but I don't
know if it could take down a mammal like
this I mean it's an amazing effort that
it's carrying that animal but I think
that this pygmy possum may already have
either been dead or sick when this
huntsman came across it this wouldn't be
great to see on your wall but what would
be great would be knowing that you've
got pygmy possums living in your
immediate environment I mean that would
be so cool to know you do receive oh oh
I recognized it went across there it was
almost hanging on by one foot at one
stage there for an instant that Mouse is
dead and possibly not by cos of the
spider it looks almost as if rigor
mortis is sitting on that tail that's
pretty like stiff and it looks like it's
you know carrying it across a wall can
you imagine the grip it's got it's
incredible it's doing it without too
much trouble and that's because it's
natural habitat is in things like trees
and bushes where it's going to be
climbing vertically and that's why it
deal with walls and rubes container on a
pole what is that contraption Wow look
at these little petty Pope's they have
the little leggy bits that are coming
off the front they are used by the male
basically mmm this is gonna get x-rated
when daddy spider loves a mummy spider
[Laughter]
basically the daddy spider jerks off
into his hand and then he goes to the
mummy spider and puts the hand inside
her it's Betty pulps there right there
the thing with spider reproduction is
that females can be quite antsy and they
can eat the male's afterwards so if you
want to try and get the genital bits
close to each other you're really
putting yourself at risk this way you
get to make a quick getaway if at all
possible all right let's see if this
life
what is she blowing him into the into
the inside of it see how camouflage he
was as soon as he hit like the ground is
that he is that the same guy Huntsman
used visual clues and vibratory clues to
find their prey so you can imagine how
many vibrations are going through that
little spiders legs and up into his
little Spidey brain a lot he's going to
be a little bit worried and he's
probably just trying to find an escape
route
unbelievable well look at him he's see
how flat he aids that's like a super
cute way of showing how his legs work to
become really flat huntsman legs are
really cool in that they're rotated a
little bit and it enables the spider to
collapse them right down and be really
flat in the container in the container
she's got the right reaction do not
panic
do not drive over the road I really love
that she hasn't just killed it outright
and that she's actually trying to get it
to move on to the nearest tree or hello
cat how amazing a cat's it's the
universal reaction but everyone does it
I do it there's no shame in that but
after a split-second of panic make sure
that your logical brain kicks in
huntsman spiders not there to hurt you
they're there because they wanna eat
your insects think of them as your
friend rather than your phone
[Music]
arts fighters cute now if you've got a
cute video of an animal I'd like to see
it I can unpack it on YouTube for you so
why don't you send it into ABC science
and if you've got a question why don't
you leave it in the comments down below
so I suppose that's it until next time
catch you later
[Music]